in the 90s Sinbad was a near constant
presence on TV and at the movies but we
don't hear too much from this one named
comedian anymore so just where did
Sinbad go let's find out
one of the main reasons Sinbad isn't as
prolific as he used to be is because his
health isn't always 100% in 2010 for
example he had to undergo knee
replacement surgery which is a costly
and painful procedure that requires a
lot of recovery time patients
essentially have to relearn to walk
Sinbad received two artificial joints or
bionic knees as he calls them alas the
new knees left one of his legs slightly
longer than the other which made his
gait become what he refers to as a pimp
walk one leg short another because I had
my knees replaced so one leg just didn't
Bend all the way out it gives me a pimp
walk some people that go I'm just pimp
walking Sinbad was knocked out of
commission again five years later when
his chronic back pain grew so unbearable
that in 2015 on his 59th birthday no
less he had to undergo double fusion
spinal surgery the procedure lasted for
ten hours but as of 2019 he's still
alive and kicking Sinbad was huge in the
90s he was on TV all the time throughout
the decade partly because he turned out
comedy special after comedy special that
ran on the likes of HBO and the
fledgling Comedy Central they aired less
and less as Comedy Central developed a
larger slate of original programming and
perhaps as a result
Sinbad produced fewer specials after
1998's nothing but the funk he focused
on movies and sitcoms and didn't tape
another solo show until 2010's
appropriately titled where you've been
four years later he delivered make me
wanna holla but it's been pretty slow
going since then Sinbad fans may
remember mark curry one of his 90s
stand-up comedy contemporaries and the
star of the ABC sitcom hangin with mr.
Cooper
in 2006 curry was doing his laundry at
home in a can of spray starch fell
behind a hot water heater and exploded
leaving second-degree burns over 20% of
his body even after a three day
medically induced coma the pain was so
bad that curry contemplated suicide in
response Curry's comedian friends
particularly Sinbad jumped into action
they talked with curry on the phone and
were generally just there for him in an
effort to lift his spirits
curry later spoke with people
magazine about his journey out of the
ordeal revealing that Sinbad making him
laugh was one of the things that lifted
his spirits Sinbad is still a touring
comic but if he's gracing a stage these
days it's far more likely that he's
doing it as a musician after buying a
drum kit and learning to play a couple
years back he formed a band for the
first time in more than 30 years it's a
jazz funk group called Memphis red and
the stank nasty band
Sinbad fronts the group singing and
playing guitar under the stage name of
his alter ego Memphis red musical
performances as Memphis red happened to
bookend Sinbad's 2014 comedy special
make me wanna holla hopefully his funk
starts influencing his comedy and
vice-versa if it hasn't already in
December 2009 the IRS went after Sinbad
for millions in uncollected taxes he
apparently hadn't paid federal income
tax in about a decade
it was so bad that a judge ordered that
he sell as 1.5 million dollar house in
Hidden Hills California
to help alleviate some of the eight
point 1 5 million dollars he owed the
government to protect himself he filed
for chapter 7 bankruptcy but the case
was later dismissed because he filled
out the wrong paperwork
regardless Sinbad was still on the hook
for his crushing tax debt and he ended
up filing for bankruptcy again in 2013
around that time he explained that his
financial problems were not a result of
squandering my fingers I didn't live
under live large I believed in me I
invested in me and I'm invested in a lot
of other people I would not change it I
would not go back a year after filing
for bankruptcy for the first time Sinbad
resorted to something that a lot of
formerly prominent stars have done
reality TV in 2010 he appeared on the
Celebrity Apprentice albeit very briefly
getting fired on the second episode of
the season amidst the disagreement with
bandanna enthusiast Bret Michaels
Sinbad later joked during an appearance
on Oprah where are they now
about his regret from being on the show
the heck is Donald Trump to fire me I
regret I didn't tell Donald Trump you
need to fire Barbara in 2011 Sinbad
starred in his own reality show entitled
Sinbad it's just family it depicted his
unique home life as he and his wife
Meredith divorced in 1992 after six
years of marriage but then Reem
married in 2002 alas the series was
canceled after just one season
Sinbad got back into scripted TV in 2018
on the Fox sitcom realm in which he
played lo rel Howery stabbed but that
also ended up being cancelled after only
one season check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]